[Music]
peruvian was developed to predict
whether a protein sequence variation
affects protein function
peruvian is able to provide predictions
for any type of protein sequence
variations including single or multiple
amino acid substitutions
single or multiple amino acid insertions
single or multiple amino acid deletions
to compute the peruvian score clustering
of blast hits is performed by cd hit
with a parameter of 75
global sequence identity the top 30
clusters of closely related sequences
form the supporting sequence set
which will be used to generate the
prediction a delta alignment score is
computed for each supporting sequence
the scores are then averaged within and
across clusters to generate the final
peruvian score
if the province score is equal to or
below a predefined threshold
the protein variant is predicted to have
a deleterious effect
if the peruvian score is above the
threshold the variant is predicted to
have a neutral effect
for maximum separation of the
deleterious and neutral variants for all
four classes of human protein variants
the default score threshold is currently
set at minus 2.5 for binary
classification
such as deleterious versus neutral to
increase the specificity of detection
and find deleterious variants with
higher confidence
a lower score threshold can also be used
such as minus 4.1
to increase the sensitivity of detection
and find more deleterious variants by
including those with lower confidence
a higher score threshold can also be
used such as minus 1.3
a summary of specificity in sensitivity
obtained using different score cutoffs
is shown here
the overall accuracy for binary
classification of protein variants
either deleterious or neutral
is about 79.5 percent for uniprot human
protein variations
and 77.9 percent for uniprot non-human
the performance of provine was also
compared with other prediction tools
such as mutation assessor
sift polyfen 2 and condel using default
score threshold suggested by individual
tools
overall the performance of peruvian is
comparable to other tools
the prediction results for the uniprot
human protein variant dataset were
obtained from multiple tools including
peruvian
sift and polyphen 2 and are summarized
in venn diagrams
overall the prediction results for 78.5
percent of disease-associated variants
and 46.8
common variants are in agreement and
shared by all three tools
in addition each tool produces correct
predictions for distinct subsets of
disease
or neutral variants combining prediction
results from multiple tools can increase
the chance of identifying functional
variants that had been missed by other
tools
in this example we are going to
investigate the effects of p53
our 273 h mutation using peruvian
first we are going to input the tp53
protein sequence in the protein sequence
query box
next enter the amino acid variations and
click the submit button
the results show that our 273 h mutation
has a deleterious effect
you can also perform multiple protein
variance analysis
using the peruvian protein batch
function
in this example here peruvian scores
were generated for all possible single
amino acid substitutions
deletions and insertions at each
position in the human protein tp53
the scores are represented as a color
intensity scale from minus 18 to five
for substitutions and insertions each
row represents one of 20 amino acids in
the variant
the amino acid residues are grouped by
polarity and charge
in general low peruvian scores are found
in conserved regions or domains and high
scores are found in non-conserved
regions
overall provine is a fast computation
software tool can predict whether an
amino acid substitution
or in dell has an impact on the
biological function of a protein